hello welcome to this video and this is
back to back here against goldman maybe
now I can actually win the winning
position if I get one okay let's see
what is coming up with him once he for
okay afraid of my bank oh man I place
place all those moves i think in
comparable frequency and he does not
know how I'm going for the banker anyway
so let's see what he goes with now 93 g3
one thing I know he takes his time ms
coup against them is really bad a 3.5
out of 12 and I know that the positions
were good enough for at least fifty
percent but here's a tough opponent it's
not going to go down without a fight so
let's see how a place this year we can
so that's a mistake h5 is very dangerous
for right now let's see what if he had
some some idea sahaja how to defend on
the King side yep wants to get counter
play immediately understandable so what
to do now I can take and pledge forms
one thing I can do enjoy immediately he
might take on c6 but i think this this
was tried before and it didn't work out
well take on 661 e5 he really needs the
light squared Bishop in this position
now this is a quite dangerous setup for
black this age 5 business in my video
series 44 chest 24 I recommended to
North Castle I mean which is a clear
recommendation as castles it's really
just a mistake so let's see how we
defense this position okay I'm taking
here I guess I don't think it helps me
if i delay this this thing okay now a
queen g5 queen age 6 is a very
straightforward way to play I wonder
yeah it is it is dangerous why not let's
not be too subtle iam
okay but now I have Bishop g4 right this
is a big problem for them Knight f3
check it's just around the corner here
Queen a4 looks like a move but I think I
can just place his sex I don't even need
to do something dramatic like be five
which might win actually before I yeah
that might win but how does he ever
defend after c 6-r threatened Knight f3
and this is unavoidable yeah I don't
think let's just do this and show me how
you defend against Knight f3 a rook move
maybe maybe your route move maybe can
can with the rook rabbit where we're
actually rookie 193 m rogue d 1 i'd take
but this is one of the better moves
maybe what does he move the night
somewhere that i don't see night night
h3 I think maybe Knight f3 is even
possible there yeah I'm just waiting now
what is doing and some can be any kind
of any kind of desperate move I'm not
going to let him out of this after the
last game which was a complete complete
route and then then I overlooked
something stupid I have not
we'll look anything stupid i I just left
the time right now anyway so let's see
what to do here Queen age six comes into
consideration or just 90 of three wins
wins the exchange of course let's just
win the exchange here and see what
happens I don't know maybe this is the
wrong approach and I should really go
for the kill him I don't know if I'm
really threatening all that much if I
play well maybe queen age 6 h 2 with a
threat and you cannot take really queen
age 6 night age 3 might might be on mmm
two
taking the exchange doesn't feel like
optimal optimal the best possible result
here really doesn't you mean age six
night age three maybe I'd like actually
check on you two maybe this is the thing
I don't know Queen h2 is a quite
substantial threat okay if I check him
now here I'm not winning this well we
can see that more fun check check check
goes to e2 I even have a double check
there okay you one shaking be three
let's no maid or something that's crazy
can also take their first come on let's
take this let's take this first and then
see what goes that goes on here Quinn h1
that's not a win crazy and if i go to
age 24 this check let's do it on my time
I've against spent so much time try to
find a mate here that I can get into
time real-time issues I probably should
have played something simple instead of
trying to checkmate him
ok this is anyway come on can't take the
root canal I can take f3 I didn't see
that oh my god mama what a wonder what
what am i doing him check really know
check check check ok
white vers I yeah okay man 22 times like
a plus a million position spoiling that
it would be too much okay so let's have
a look at the post-mortem of this game
and there are a couple of key situations
one is that castles is just a mistake
ready it really after h5 gets right into
trouble it's something that the computer
also would appreciate if it gets down to
a little more depth IAM if you for
example this is step 19 for stock 47 and
yeah you now see that it goes down a
little bit i invested really lots of
time castles is just not good white gets
into as I said get into a big attack Ian
so each form now we tried to say I know
you see that the engine very quickly
sees how how bad it it has become take
sticks and now this direct attack IAM a
queen takes you three is results already
okay oh my god i can't just take this at
you he just resigned sigh okay this this
is also of course quite quite good yeah
Bishop d7 wins because g3 Hanks which i
did not see this is also quite quite
nice minus seven yeah I probably should
have just played quicker I mean
everything is better for black you just
said I wanted to to do something that
like wins and the other does win b2
hangs minus 8 km k and it was a major
with Queen B to computer find some made
but yeah okay this is this is enough we
can go here actually I'm not winning the
Queen I cannot go see five but be 5f
with 45 and checkmate okay then that
wins the house I think I've photo found
that ha here the Queen gets lost you
have the day
if you interested in this foot wide um I
i recommend to play something slow here
like a three or rugby one trying for
this just not castle this position was
reached in the game Nakamura aronian and
nakamura played this with black I'm
sorry aronia Nakamura ally camera was
back and aronia played a three in this
position which is also fine move and
nakamura in this comments also gives
castles as a bad move it has a terrible
score d 4 is also a possibility but here
black can play age 5 or can take this is
also quite nice this kind of position is
quite satisfactory for mes night f5 yeah
but Sir it's a roughly equal situation I
liked like I have to save it I think
that of course why term can can play
this okay hope you'll enjoy the game
yeah thanks for watching